I could if I felt like they can Gotti
tomorrow it's that easy and okay says
anything different then they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about and
and just in my culture guys will do
anything I want what I want I don't live
that life anymore so you know my message
isn't about gaudy or guys like gaudy my
message is for those guys in our prisons
the inner-city kids or the tough guys in
those prisons that are sending messages
out to me John keep doing what you don't
want save some kids lives because all
eyes were ruined let's not let's hope
these kids not ruin this right yeah you
know you talk about gaudy and I think I
said this earlier you hit on gaudy
before you know before we wrap it up is
you know some of his family members are
really guys that their family suffered
and you know and I've talked about Gotti
you're talking about God he's family
members yeah yes some of them also in
the life in jails and some of the kids
and some of the things that went on I
want to see him tell somebody just was a
good life you know I want to see him say
you know I want my son in this life
right because there's nobody's gonna say
this so if you could find me one I'd
love to get on the air with you with him
I'll come meet you and sit down
someone's proud of that life what dummy
wants their kid in that life right call
your father to call each kid and this
kids out there that don't have parents
that aren't able to anybody to tell them
this but those kids that don't have
parents there's no excuse to be in the
street I used as an excuse I have
parents but you know none of us come
from a perfect life and my parents
weren't the greatest parents in the
world none of nobody's parents are
perfect then we're not perfect but to
push somebody in the street you got to
be a real scumbag so I'm gonna keep
doing what I'm doing I'm not pushing
okay that way I'll push him this way and
hopefully I can reach them and some
adults too and you know people last you
well he's just talking about this gang
so I know a lot of gangstas no one's
that were gonna say you're not gonna hit
me deny that I'm not friends with a lot
of gangsters right I'm not choosing
their path for them they could choose
their own mm-hmm you know if that's what
they choose unfortunately I think
eventually they're gonna sell for the
path they're taking right but I'm not
gonna choose I mean they're friends when
we joke
you know I'd use the word I'm retired
right that's my word you're retired I'm
retired you look like you still put a
beating on somebody you know listen I
work out every day push-ups in the gym
my box still I'm still playing around
with bags and all that yeah but you know
it's in a positive way again yeah you
get in the ring you play around with
guys yeah you know if you weren't a ring
in your sparring right without the
attitude of the street the street is is
like I said listen I'm involved in a
fight business I'm friends with a lot of
professional fighters and you know we
joke about it all the time because
there's guys out in the street have no
idea some of these guys are and they
want to fight them so you know they say
the same thing I'm saying you want to
fight you can fight all day go to gyms
every day you can find a million guys to
fight you're that insecure go to go to a
gym all right you know so but that you
know my message is that and hopefully
you know some of the things I'm doing
now is gonna be magazines and the shows
and the TV series they're all coming now
so that she is gonna be great yeah I got
a new book coming out yeah tell me about
your book what's uh what's it called
darkest hour - it's coming out with
Susan pike is my writing I did talk is
how one it was about when I was a child
- 17 Pride - that I got his rules with
george anastasia and i have a hand book
out called prison rules the do's and
don'ts so you don't find yourself in
prison and the situation for adults
young you know kids and for parents that
need to try to reach their children
maybe they you know and that's that's a
book people that are imprisoned they can
get their hands on yeah all these books
are you know through the internet
through Amazon through through Barnes &
Noble and darkest hour - should be out
by February and that'll be more of us
hardcore mafia stuff and some of the
killings and shootings and things that
went on at prison systems so that that
there book would I think be a little
more
to the point can you tell me like what
it like what did you have to do like how
did you get out of prison so quick did
you have like good behavior was there I
mean it might have been quick for you
but it wasn't quick for me I mean listen
when you're alright obviously but I mean
what I meant by that was like you you
know you did about 18 years total right
yeah and you're originally sentence of
30 well 30 no I was facing 30 when I
came back okay i sat down with the
government after I had the paperwork on
gaudí and some of the other guy said
okay you know 54 guys went and testified
against me in a grand jury so you know
holy show wasn't one or two and then I
some other shows and if somebody's
interested they could look what I said I
named boss after boss that were
testifying given information so these
guys these guys betrayed you ya ain't
switching this around they betrayed me I
didn't betray them by their set of rules
they all rided later on I come in and
and I said that's it after I went
through each boss and each captain and
they're making statements all of them
against me and so you know what I'll get
into all that crap people can look at my
books and read or watch somebody or the
interviews and they can see it but this
is the typical what I said about the
treachery of life I was betrayed I never
betrayed anybody god he betrayed me I
was in a penitentiary even though he was
my enemy at that time he still betraying
what we believed was a life of a good
soldier a mobster but that's that's the
reality of what happens but I did on
this case back to the 30 years is Brazil
extradition law when you come back I'm
facing to do 25 years when I did two and
a half years in Brazil I was supposed to
get nine years credit because of the
conditions there right so if you give me
the nine years that you're supposed to
give me and I supposed to do 25 my
supposed to do 16 more write it at 16 I
took a 12-year sentence I got it down to
ten so I did a lot of time for what I
did actually on you know laws because
these guys people don't understand that
take please on murder Singh at four or
five years or six years don't cooperate
some of them do and they get less but
you know when you when they're in that
position and whatever the situation that
cases I know bosses got ten years old
they went on a run they caught him they
had two separate trials and they still
only got ten years without cooperation
because of the situation that depends on
that have weapons
so we'll get in through one last thing
before I look I never been caught with
any kind of crime nothing on this case
on the case that I was facing life and I
went on a run and I had the extradition
to 30 years so you know it's only from
what the Gottis of somebody will say
rats
it was informants it was only testimony
it wasn't me selling a drug and someone
caught me it wasn't me getting caught
with kilos it wasn't me on an audio tape
or video tape it wasn't me out of
shooting or out of killing it wasn't me
getting quote with a used weapon it
wasn't me anyway so when people use the
excuse of well it was all rats against
me and everybody's a riot rat rat rat
and they talk that they usually rat like
out he was nobody knocked on my door and
said oh we're gonna arrest you for all
these crimes because we don't like you
listen it was people trying to save
their own [ __ ] now yeah and mostly you
know the mob guys that testified against
me and gave information on the sneaked
against me and we're performance but
listen I'm ok with it my life's not at
that point anymore I don't give a [ __ ]
what he did I don't really give a [ __ ]
wash your hands but don't change the
story line story line is you guys right
it betrayed me I left this country left
my children left my family stood in
those concentration camps not to talk
against my enemies or my friend Jesus
all betrayed me and I came home and that
changed so when someone says of who
betrayed who I didn't betray anybody by
those rules but those rules and that
life is gone for me yeah but we'll keep
that record straight that I never got
caught
so this paperwork they can go check I
never been caught what a crime so I
wasn't a talker and these shows now my
life's different so I can go on here and
talk and be on you know honestly exactly
what happened but I've never been caught
with a crime the ones I got caught pried
out with a gun I did my three and a half
years I did my year I did my whatever
time I did on all the salts and I went
to jails from this case here Rico
indictment for a life sentence and I ran
and I went to 20 countries when they
caught me it was only from informant
after format mob guy after mob guy made
guy you have to make guy boss of
different families all given information
against me not the other way around so
somewhere
this public they switched that around
and they thought that hey this guy was
given now I left this country
I spent millions of dollars to fight and
left my children fight with lawyers
attorneys investigators I lost my family
over this so when people say I betrayed
something they better do a little more
research and find out who betrayed oh
and there's nothing public information
you can get court documents if I've ever
been caught with any kind of crime
nothing Wow
[Music]
[Laughter]